Україна - це моя друга Батьківщина!
Волонтерство - це моє внутрішнє співчуття.
Україна надіслала війська, щоб допомогти США боротися з "Аль-Каїдою".
І тому багато ветеранів вважають, що Україна була там,
коли ми її потребували, тому, ми маємо бути тут, коли Україна потребує допомоги.
Я вирішив, що можу зробити більше, оскільки в мене є досвід конструювання.
Дуже люблю цих людей, їх прагнення свободи
і все, що відбувається тут через війну, стимулює мене допомагати!
Колишній віцеконсул Гвінеї в Україні,
експолковник Повітряних cил США
та інженер-конструктор з Румунії.
Сьогодні ці люди з різних куточків світу працюють на одному будмайданчику під Києвом як волонтери:
хтось з лопатою в руках, хтось - голіруч розбирає рештки знищеного РФ будинку.
Немає значення, я дипломат, я президент організації або я бізнесмен.
Я людина. Я маю бути корисним. Я маю допомогти тим людям, яким це потрібно.
Я не будівельник, але можу принести, можу подати, можу різати, можу все зробити своїми руками.
Ісса родом з Гвінеї. Він говорить українською понад три десятки років,
адже весь цей час у Києві він займав декілька дипломатичних посад
і брав участь у сотнях конференцій та офіційних заходів,
присвячених культурним зв’язкам України та Гвінеї.
Зараз він працює Президентом Африканської Ради в Україні.
Маю друзів, які колись працювали миротворцями.
В тому числі працювали в Африці.
І коли один з них сказав, що працює в цій добровольчій організації, "Добробат",
я сказав, що я хочу бути разом з ними і допомогти чим зможу.
За понад півтора року Ісса Садіо Діалло доклав руки до відновлення більше сотні будинків українців.
Сьогодні з командою волонтерів з Києва він розбирає завали у одному з районів столиці,
куди в грудні поцілила російська ракета.
З Ісою познайомився я потужно.
За цих волонтерів я взагалі не знаю, куди їх цілувати і як це.
Тому що я не думав, що є така організація в Києві.
Ці хлопці, я вже їх знаю в лице. Ви молодці, звісно.
І паркан, тут же було розбито, все лежало в сусіда.
Роблять, я не знаю, на якому ентузіазмі!
Віктор Демченко вже вчетверте зустрічає будівельників-добровольців у себе на подвір’ї.
Точніше на тому, що від нього лишилося після обстрілу РФ:
половина будинку та гараж з укриттям знищено.
Пенсіонер та його дружина дивом вціліли.
Ось це будинок, ось ця стінка повністю була розбита.
І дах висів. І щоб дах не впав, ми вирішили з хлопцями, теж допомогли тоді, блоки затягнути, старі почистити.
Тут були азербайджанці, казахи, німці були.
І ось Ісса крайній раз тут теж був. Допомагають сильно, тому що я не знаю, як без них це б було.
Сьогодні вперше допомагати пану Віктору відновити оселю приїхав 57-річний Девід Греков.
По приїзду з Каліфорнії рік тому американець хотів долучитися до інтернаціонального легіону ЗСУ,
оскільки має військовий досвід: в минулому він - полковник Повітряних сил США.
Під час війни в Іраку він керував постачанням амуніції на фронт,
а пізніше - брав участь у секретних спецопераціях з доставки зброї.
Захист України він вважав своїм обов’язком ще задовго до повномасштабного вторгнення РФ.
Багато людей не зрозуміли, і це так, те, що після терористичних атак у Нью-Йорку 11 вересня,
коли США увійшли до Афганістану, щоб знищити "Аль-Каїду",
Україна надіслала війська, щоб допомогти США, допомогти нам боротися з "Аль-Каїдою".
І тому багато ветеранів вважають, що Україна була там, коли ми її потребували,
тому, ми маємо бути тут, коли Україна потребує допомоги.
Вік та здоров’я не дали змоги Девіду Грекову взяти зброю до рук у складі ЗСУ.
Він почав волонтерити і доставляти на фронт аптечки для військових.
А в перервах між цим - долучався до розбору завалів після обстрілів РФ у різних куточках України.
Минулого тижня ми допомагали розбирати завали початкової школи в Києві.
Звісно, також донати, постачання обладнання, дронів, одягу, медичних аптечок,
евакуація для цілих родин у безпечні місця.
Є так багато способів допомогти.
Якими б не були ваші навички, ви можете приїхати сюди, в Україну, і застосувати їх.
Свої професійні навички на будмайданчиках в Україні протягом року використовує Віктор Буд.
Він родом з Румунії, але вже 5 років живе у Великобританії
і на момент вторгнення РФ в Україну працював там як інженер-конструктор.
На пошкоджених атаками Росії об’єктах він допомагає і з плануванням роботи, і долучається до усіх задач сам.
Я вирішив, що можу зробити більше, оскільки в мене є досвід конструювання.
Я виготовляв опалювальні системи, електричні системи.
Багато разів з нами були волонтери, які не мали досвіду будівельних робіт,
тому ми показували їм, як робити подібне.
У мене з'явилося багато друзів за один рік тут.
Дуже люблю цих людей, їхні прагнення свободи.
Все, що відбувається тут через війну, стимулює мене допомагати.
О, Девіде!
Ми з ним були разом в Миколаєві, розбирали від піску будинки.
Іноземці настільки часто доєднуються до команди українських волонтерів під час відбудови,
що один з жителів Києва, який працює разом із ними, заснував власний музей волонтерства.
У ньому він збирає десятки подарунків і артефактів від небайдужих,
що приїздять до України з-за кордону допомагати з відновленням.
Ми почали колекціонувати інформацію про іноземних волонтерів, які приїздять допомагати Україні.
У нас є зі США, з Фенікса, з Німеччини, теж з нами працювали.
Ми збираємо те, що волонтери роблять своїми руками.
Вони віддають шеврони свої, емблеми.
Це цікаво буде потім, коли війна закінчиться.
Навіть попри морозну погоду взимку, щотижня на кількагодинну роботу
на зруйнованих об’єктах в українських містах продовжують приїздити іноземці - як новачки, так і досвідчені.
Охочих формують у групи, забезпечують трансфером та навчають за участі фахівців.
Потрапити в проєкт відбудови можуть представники навіть тих країн, які не говорять англійською чи українською.
Був такий випадок, в нас був волонтер з Бразилії, він тільки знав португальську.
Мусив з телефоном за ним ходити. Я з перекладачем в телефоні показував, перекладав.
Наша команда за 2023 рік виїжджала багато разів на об’єкти.
І це понад 10 тисяч волонтерів.
При чому це волонтери з різних країн: з Норвегії, з Швеції, Франції, Сполучених Штатів.
Наприклад, Росс Коел з Солт-Лейк-Сіті, який займаються побудовою соціального житла,
долучався до нас неодноразово.
З Великобританії, з Нової Зеландії.
Дуже багато людей, які долучилися до нас.
Іноземці, з якими поспілкувалася DW під час відбудови будинку планують і надалі підтримувати Україну.
Волонтери-іноземці Девід Греков і Віктор Буд, що приїхали до під час повномасштабного вторгнення,
не покидали країну з дня свого прибуття.
Ісса Садіо Діалло, якого життя пов'язало з Україною ще тридцять років тому,
каже, що нині він відчуває себе українцем.
Україна - це моя друга батьківщина.
Я маю тут дружину українку.
Маю тут доньок, які теж тут проживають в Києві, навчалися тут, в Києві.
Я маю зробити все, що можливо, щоб зупинити війну.
Волонтерство - це моє внутрішнє співчуття.
У мене немає громадянства України.
Я не можу бути військовим, але можу працювати добровольцем,
щоб допомогти, чим можу, щоб бути корисним.